فكر في المدة التي سيستغرقها
تقشير الثوم واحدًا تلو الآخر بدلاً من
القيام بذلك حيث تحصل على رأس كامل من
الثوم مقشر في حوالي 10 ثوانٍ،
دعني أعرض لك حيلة سريعة حول كيفية
تقشير الثوم،
لذا قم أولاً بتقطيع الثوم لكشف كل شيء
القرنفل هو المفتاح لأنك تريد
إزالة الجلد من الأعلى والأسفل
وسنقوم فقط بإزالة هذه
الطبقة الخارجية من الجلد ثم
ستضع الثوم في حاوية صلبة
يمكن أن تكون أوعية معدنية  يمكن أن يكون جرة ماسونية
أي شيء له جانب صلب
يكسر الرأس
لفصل الفصوص بالكاد
ولكننا لا نقوم بتقشيرها وهزها
بقوة كما يعني ذلك حقًا
واعتني بهزها، وسيخرج الجلد
مباشرة من الجزء الوحيد  الطريقة التي يمكنك بها
إفساد هذا الأمر هي إذا لم تهتز بقوة
كافية أو إذا كنت تستخدم شيئًا ناعمًا مثل
البلاستيك
لا يعمل